this man likes some of the hip-hop music
maybe little DJing Carlisle co-founder
David Rubenstein she recorded a holiday
video for his investors and no it wasn't
talking about their biggest deals of the
year he took a page from dr. Dre the two
know each other well since Carlisle was
one of the top investors in Beats
headphones before Apple bought it so
watch this takes a lot of brains to do
what we do looking for a way to make
some dough for you energy commodity we
do it all so pick up the phone and give
us a call for mezzanine private equity
car Law Group is the place to be
we're global we're mobile for aiming to
please only gold mine surveil PLT cell P
server help ease help ease LP silver LPS
tailpiece LP survey help ease haven't
done anything like this really since my
bar mitzvah
okay so I've had the pleasure who's
seeing this already what do you think
I'm glad to see he's putting his duke
education to work I think that was
pretty impressive
rhyming private equity he got corporate
mezzanine in there there's not too many
hip-hop songs with mezzanine and far be
it for me to give advice to David
Rubenstein but I think he should keep
his day job I think you should keep this
day job keep his day job he does it well
that was very humorous but guess what
when you're this successful you can kind
of do whatever you want
and I'm pretty sure everyone who works
for you is going to tell you you are the
smartest funniest best-looking guy at
the party and we'll leave it at that
because I don't respond to that David
Rubenstein channeling his inner dr. Dre